it was a power vacuum that was never
going to last very long with rorke
morris's exit from yellowstone season 4
was going to need a new pair of greedy
hands trying to wrestle control of the
yellowstone dutton ranch and its land
away from the family whose name hangs on
a shingle enter caroline warner the
relatively new ceo of roark's company
market equities played by australian
actress jackie weaver caroline's first
appearance on the series seems to
indicate a change of tact for the firm
she hints that they're going to win out
over the dutton family not with guns and
violence but rather by bringing the full
pressure of their financial resources to
bear on the ranch and its owners to make
them sell up
they might have met their match with
caroline part of caroline's plan
includes buying off neighbors to isolate
the family and force them to give up the
ranch but things rarely stay peaceful on
yellowstone for long if caroline is
really going to be the new big bad of
yellowstone then chances are she's not
going to be afraid to get her hands
dirty when push comes to shove
watch out for the elks cat
i cannot wait to pave this place over
when the time for intimidation arrives
you can trust the star playing the
dutton's latest vote to bring the
necessary firepower here are some places
you might recognize her from jackie
weaver's career in film and television
can be divided into two halves in her
first foray she was a young theater
actor in her native australia making the
jump from the stage to the screen with
great success after appearing in a
number of small parts on australian
television in the late 1960s she was
cast as the female lead of the 1971
comedy stork playing anna the
promiscuous love interest of the naive
title character weaver's portrayal of
anna her first ever role in a feature
film would wind up winning her the
australian film institute's award for
best actress in a leading role stork was
merely the first in a series of parts we
were landed in films that would become
known as the australian new wave she had
a small part in peter weir's 1975
classic picnic at hanging rock and won a
supporting actress award from the
australian film institute for her role
as josie in 1976's caddy
after jackie weber's initial success in
aussie indie film she spent decades
primarily working in the theater of her
native country she told the av club the
parts got a bit lean for me after a
while in movies but i never wanted for
work at all and that suited me fine i
love working in the theater animal
kingdom in 2010 wasn't her first film
back but it was the one that launched
her late career resurgence in it weaver
played the australian crime matriarch
smurf cody who sits at the center of a
sprawling web of corrupt cops and armed
robbers keeping the family thriving and
out of trouble
[Music]
i feel sick about this
i'm not happy at all not one little bit
the role earned her a second australian
film institute best actress award and
earned her an academy award nomination
for best supporting actress weber told
the av club it was a gift it was a huge
gift and it speaks to the generosity of
americans how warmly i was embraced i
was at no shortage of offers after the
first oscar nom but after the second
well i've never really looked back like
i can't do everything i'm offered jackie
weaver's second oscar nomination came
two years after animal kingdom when she
played a kindly gentler mother figure in
davido russell's silver linings playbook
weavers died in the wool philadelphia
and was occasionally harried and often
opinionated but she still functioned as
the relative calm in her tumultuous
family's storm looking for his wedding
videos you're making krabby snacks and
homemade yeah come on dad be nice come
on she's making krabby snacks and
homemades
jackie weaver spent much of her
post-silver linings playbook period
showcasing her range alternating between
comedies including the disaster artists
palms and stage mother and horror films
that include stoker the voices and the
grudge in 2018 she took a role in
netflix's smash hit horror thriller bird
box starring sandra bullock weaver
played cheryl one of a group of
survivors bullock's mallory finds in a
house shortly after the arrival of the
mysterious entities that drive all who
look upon them to suicide though the
genre has been good to her career weaver
herself told the sydney morning herald
that she rarely watches horror movies
even one she appeared in she told the
newspaper i always say my idea of
recreation is not being terrified i have
enough terror after the yell action so i
don't want it in my leisurely pursuits
too check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite actors are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]